other than the NFL draft what we're
talking about these days is the last
dance on ESPN the fantastic documentary
Jason hare the director was on
yesterday's show right at this time and
we go to our phone lines and joining us
as a guy who is all over that
documentary this past weekend because
what was documented was the highly
documented hate between the Bulls and
the bad boys Pistons years and a guy who
is on that team and then won
championships with two other teams and
the rest of his stellar NBA career John
Salley here on the Rich Eisen show how
are your spider Sally man I couldn't
wait to get on this show what's the been
five years since I begged you to be on
your carpet John you've never been on
this shell before of course you have man
yeah you know I had to call the wife and
send flowers I am so glad that you are
on John let's put it that way is there
anything you learned from the
documentary over the weekend yeah what'd
you learn I learned why one we didn't
realize that we still are on the mind of
Michael Jordan so imagine being the
greatest player to ever play in the NBA
and he goes to sleep thinking about you
I really appreciated that we also really
we didn't know the inner workings I know
Jerry Krause was with Shady
but I didn't know what he did to Scottie
and I didn't know Scottie had such bad
representation I'm doing a seven-year
deal but I knew Michael was that intense
I've been around Michael since I mean I
went to visit Georgia Tech when they
were playing North Carolina and the next
two years I was playing against MJ so
I've been with him with frat brothers
I've been with him since 1982
so I knew he was intense I know how it
is the play I know how it is the play
with magic in a pickup game and in a
real game so imagine what it's like to
play against MJ in a pickup game
no referees it's ridiculous so we we do
that but that's the way we were in
Detroit we were mentally strong all that
and I'm so happy I don't know you know
calling a thug and and like that not
really if you played against Bob Lanier
or I got hit in the head by artis
Gilmore I still got the night in his day
mark Maurice Lucas come on you gotta be
kidding me we were just playing the game
the way the game was played at this when
he came in the lead took a turn so we
were the last of the Mohicans old I mean
okay so you just gave me a lot to unpack
right there John so when was the first
time you met Jordan you'd literally met
him when you guys were teammate
teenagers that's what you're saying yeah
I was 18 years old he was 19 I went to
visit Georgia Tech they played against
him and then the next year you know you
do things in the summertime I was at
five star basketball camp with Lenny
bias all the time we you know we would
uh if you go and play in North Carolina
I wound up going with David Falk the
same agent the pro serve at the time and
yeah I was always in the midst of it so
like I did my first TV show the John
Salley show in 1988 and my first guest
was Michael Jordan so I went to the
hotel picked him up I said your footage
it's amazing I was my that was my guy
still is and you know for it to turn
into what it turned into
everybody was thinking hey divider there
it was people didn't realize Isaiah's
from Chicago and I was his city and then
Michael came and made the people in the
city like the Bulls but they were like
they ride their fan so it was not really
hate I think he it was the attitude
about playing against the Pistons it
really revved them I'm tell you one
story rich I'm I get on I get on the
Bulls and you know where you know we
scrimmage once in a while so all of a
sudden I'm sorry Phil send Michael and
Scottie home you know we're gonna talk
to the guys he goes alright we're
playing for minutes so guys are ready to
play Michael Scottie are not there
Venice's off to the side dennis is uh
he's gonna play and Michael walks back
in the gym and he has on just the campus
shoes
low tops he goes not Phil no I knew you
were gonna do a scrimmage no no no no to
put the Pistons over there I tell you
what all three Pistons Ron Harper and
and and and giving somebody else against
them and he is playing against the
team's he played against this is the
notice this is on the 96 bowls right
when when on a 96 ball right he's not
taped
he may have on ankle socks I'm not
exaggerating and feels like you can't
stop MJ from what he wants to do all of
a sudden he gets a steal and I'm lagging
back and I turn around and come I'm
gonna try to block your shot and I turn
he's in the air and his middle section
of his body is lying by my head and he's
like blocked this female dog and I like
what happens I go back to the hotel
which is across just over the fence from
the from the practice field and I called
my mother and I said ma I just saw the
greatest player of all time she said it
took you this long to say that I go I'm
not gonna say it publicly but he just
did something I didn't see since I was
playing in Brooklyn when we didn't get
taped and we walk converse sneakers on
concrete and people were jumping 40
inches off the ground 50 inches off the
ground this guy was amazing
well I remember that to this day like he
was playing against the Pistons when he
was playing and that pick up that's what
I'm saying is that is that John John
Salley here on the Rich Eisen show is
that your teammates in 96 he's already
got several trophies in the case this is
he's now back for the second time with
the Bulls right after his White Sox
hiatus and he's still even though you're
his teammate and same with Ron Harper he
still have used it Harper's a calf who
he had to get past and then you're still
a piston that he
to get past and and he just that's part
of his fire that he he can't forget that
you stood in his way and you prevented
him from having more trophies in the
case that's how greedy he was so how how
did how did that ever resolve itself I
guess you would just be somebody that
you you knew and never there at the
beginning and I'll hold that against you
forevermore is that the way it is John
no actually no that's the the best thing
about MJ MJ whole thing's he was gone
for ten minutes at four five six and and
if and if it didn't happen the way it
happened with Scottie it would have been
it would have been what would have been
nine championships in ten years if they
would have literally had the same
mentality as the Boston Celtics and
played them until the wheels fell off it
no one would have it would have
literally been the great one of the
greatest second greatest franchise to
the Boston Celtics
according to championships it would have
well the Lakers now but sure it was
amazing on what he and it's not a hate
as a person he loved the game of
basketball and and it's that competition
Dennis Rodman said it really well we
would play the game for free you get
paid for the other stuff right and MJ
being there like early in the morning we
will start practice at 10 o'clock 10
o'clock boom boom boom all right we're
gonna do 45 minutes of either this
weight training this is stuff against
the wall with the heavy balls you're
gonna run you're gonna do that and
Scottie and Michael go in and watch
SportsCenter they run in and they sit on
the table or they get in I so it got
onto them or heat and they're watching
SportsCenter why we're doing 45 minutes
of working out and I and I was like I'm
not complaining but I'm wondering wow
this is amazing
I said how was that you know Scottie and
Michael get up at 7:00 and work out and
then they come to practice with us
I was like you're you're kidding me he
goes not and hop is like and I'm at
those workouts and I still got to stay
in here with out here with y'all they
worked out 7:00 in the morning till
night then we'll come to practice get a
good treatment then practice with us
that's how intense MJ was then after
practice shower and MJ would get in the
pool and do to work out in the pool and
it's interesting John is that is it from
the documentary it does seem that all
that work ethic in terms of working out
and keeping making sure his body was
strong was born out of the the battles
with with the bad boys from what we saw
in the few minutes I have left I do want
to hit you on on all of that did you
know at the time did you not shake hands
did you want to shake hands what what
what no what happened because I say I
said that Bob that lambier came up with
that idea just as the 91 Eastern
Conference Finals was ending I didn't
agree with it in 91 I don't agree with
it now I understand we took a stand as a
team but as personally remember this
this even though we're a team were 12
individuals 12 individual companies I
had to literally I said Chuck put me
back in the game and he was like come on
Sal you can't get any more points I go
you got to put me back because I don't
want to be a part of what's about to
happen and they walked off and then when
the game was over first person I went up
to is his money that's my frat brother
adapt him up and then I went to Horace
and and Scottie who was standing
together to the coach everybody because
Scott Hastings as well all the guys on
us on on the team that was on a court we
went we shook the hair I just didn't
think right then Isaiah said it was an
emotional time and it was a it was a
knee-jerk reaction I didn't think they
were gonna shake the building Bill's
hand even if he would have stick but I
just think it just me it wasn't who I
was it's not who I am to my friends and
I will answer my fraternity brother I'm
not who I am - I'm just not that
kind of person I'm gonna try to beat the
wheels off you while I'm playing against
you because I want to win I don't want
you to win but after the competition it
it's back to you know who's buying the
first round and you know what club we
going to it's it's back to being human
and that was that's the difference I can
turn it on and turn it off yeah I guess
and and Isiah seems to think that's what
kept him off the dream team would you
agree with that
I think I I agree and I and I agree you
know part of it Michael's like mad I
said oh come on you know one grow up all
about 50 it was then - MJ really doesn't
know he's competitive like that with
anything you can play anything against
MJ and he's going to be that same
competitive person you could pitch
pennies he's gonna be man he's gonna -
look she's gonna be that person so it's
not a bad person
that's MJ that's why he's the greatest
of all time and I do think it hurt I was
there on that point I think because it
should have been the one time they had a
picture of Isaiah and and the money
shaking hand after that a no one could
have said anything after but they were
able to use it again and like Isaiah
said the only two people he hurt ever
said anything about the dream team was
Scottie and um and Malone and you know I
they should have been and I think
there's no way he shouldn't have been
there Chuck Daly was a coach so Dumars
on a squad yeah great but you know
Isaiah was supposed to be on that tape
but that it's fine he was on dream team
- no I know that but the fact that he
wasn't so I I guess that's what it was
it's personal against Isaiah that that
Jordan would be there and saying I'm
fine playing with Dumars and for Chuck
Daly but I just can't help I say on that
he wouldn't do that
Michael Michael was gonna go no matter
who you put off the clock because he was
going to represent America Dennis and as
you really do see it was the biggest
Nike infiltration of adidas ever that's
when they drop posters that's one of
that's when the world got to see
Michael Jordan and Nike so it was it was
he was gonna go no matter what the big
thing was magic was back here remember
this was a year after it was the next
year after the HIV and then it was after
he handed the trophy off to Michael and
he had to get Larry Bird to play so it
was it was a big thing
pushing the NBA and somebody made that
decision it wasn't it definitely wasn't
a player playing is not saying hey I'm
not gonna be on dream team because
Isaiah's offense know that there's not
that kind of hate no it can't be so who
made the decision do you think jeong-ja
dress is so David Stern what he wanted
to promote as the NBA I think the NBA
marketing was a part of that like he's
one of these as a is one of the greatest
plays I've ever played against one of
the greatest players to ever play in the
NBA in the stats that we're bragging
about Steph Curry the one of the
greatest point guards to play Isaiah had
those numbers in year six and beyond so
it's it and he never was they was always
there to deal with somebody obviously
didn't want to promote the mentality or
what that we had going on they were
moving on check out what they moved onto
they moved on to Phoenix they moved on
to Utah Jazz the Chicago Bulls what a
staple San Antonio was gonna come up a
lando with on to come up they made a
mistake by not putting Shaquille on the
team that was that was those were
mistakes and if you were gonna market
because that would have been the
different team but we they needed to
have Stockton on that team we needed
Chris Mullin on that team we had a we
had an unbelievable look Chris Mullin
one of my favorite players people forgot
he was Audrey beam what you needed that
so it it it was I think it was a it was
a mess up but I think the mess up came
from the backlash from the world media
about what happened with the Bulls
John I've got about 30 seconds left tell
me about N stock what do you
doing with that John and stock n and the
word stock I got to you know I was in
the medical supply business you know you
got to keep your business going when you
not make a hook shot and too bad for
this pandemic but it was definitely
needed and I thought I'm gonna make sure
the state of California has everything
we need we make everything in America
face shields mass hand sanitizers so I'm
um everybody stay home listen to the
Rich Eisen show you know every job
that's what I'm saying
you're great you're gonna get out online
you're good man and online a ten stock
calm his orders and back medical and
stock medical John let's get you back on
in the next couple weeks I'd love to
keep chatting with you about all this
you're the best thank you hey you
watched all the way to the end thanks
for that watch more right here